- You've got two boys.
Do you guys bond a lot? How do you bond?
- We bond a lot.
I'm really lucky, I'm very close to them.
We ski together.
- You're like the coolest
family in the, what the hell?
- There's my boys, there they are.
I'm trying to keep up
with them, it's tough.
Tough to keep up with those abs,
but I'm trying.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, we, I have a new
show on Netflix coming,
we'll talk about, but
it's a few months off,
that I co-created with my son John Owen.
- Oh wow.
- My son Matthew is, he's
in the finance world.
So now I'm really learning
about their work lives.
It's a whole, you know, it's
a whole different phase,
where you get them through childhood.
Then all of a sudden
it's like, how's work?
- I know.
- It's super cool.
- I know, I have friends
that have older kids.
And it's just like, it almost becomes like
a different kind of
friendship with your kid.
- Yeah.
- Like, because
they're now out of your home,
and making poor decisions
all on their own.
- That's right, that you
don't know about anymore,
'cause they're not at home.
- I know.
And you know what, don't tell me.
Unless I need to know or
you need to get out of jail.
So, is it true that you once
scared them though on a camping trip?
- Oh, oh.
- 'Cause this is traumatic.
- Yeah. See, I, so yeah.
So we went camping. They
were probably eight and six.
And I would always tell
them stories about Bigfoot.
- Yeah.
- And so I decided, we were
going to the Pacific Northwest
where Bigfoot supposedly lives.
So I rented a really
elaborate Bigfoot costume,
and I hid it in the Winnebago
that we were driving.
And then, I popped out in
the middle of the night
and walked around the
campfire in the distance,
making like horrible noises.
It was really, it was so
sick. It was the best.
- My kids are six and eight.
They would never sleep again.
- They, well one of 'em, Matthew,
came up and kicked me
and the you know whats.
- That's bold.
- And I was like,
you know what? He's good.
This kid's gonna grow up to be somebody.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
What'd the other one do?
- He vomited.
(Kelly laughing)
- It's like you know
who they are in crisis.
- That's right. Yeah, yeah.
Fight or flight?
- That's amazing.
Yeah, I love that one.
And you said the costume,
it was over like -
- Well the problem was
I hadn't tried it on.
I just stupidly assumed it would fit.
And so when I put it on,
the eye holes were up here.
And I couldn't, I was like Ahhhhhh.
- Probably looked more scary.
- Well, cause I was staggering.
- Yeah.
Until you were kicked in
that (beep) by your son.
- It was definitely a family highlight,
for sure.
- That's amazing.